the lunchtime rush in this Cafe in South
London here like most businesses around
the country there's the same pressures
Rising costs cash-strapped consumers and
now the disruption from strikes right
now with the increases uh in the living
costs and the strikes probably the worst
situation since holding so you've had
your ups and downs for it but with a bit
of help now I take this to the last
thing you need at this time when you
just felt things were getting back to
normal and lost it's a reminder that for
many businesses the real Damage Done by
the industrial action the transport
strikes in particular is what it does to
the pre-Christmas Rush does it push the
economy deeper into the deep freeze
while economic output bounced in October
the chancellor says it could be a brief
respite before a tough winter
truthfully it is likely to get worse
before it gets better which makes it
even more difficult when we have a big
public sector strikes going on at the
moment but we have a plan in place the
strikes you say will make it worse
though will they well we have to be very
careful we recognize the position the
unions hold is completely sincere
because of the challenge of 11 inflation
on the other hand we also have a
sincerely held position which is that we
don't want to do anything that would
lock in that high inflation rate that
private sector pays only about seven
percent public sector pay is running at
about two percent there is an enormous
Gap that's opening up now well I don't
say for a moment that these aren't very
sincerely held positions but it's not
fair for them to get closer to the
private sector rate of inflation well
the right answer in that situation then
is to follow an independent process that
comes to a fair balance between the
worries people have about high inflation
affecting their pay packet and the
government's concern not to lock in high
inflation for the long run what the
treasury is really worried about aside
from inflation is that if they overrule
those pay review bodies you get a kind
of Snowball Effect with different parts
of the public sector saying well what
about us so instead I'm told they're
working on a patchwork of different
deals small microdeals rather than a big
number which they hope can unthaw
relations
as this winter of discontent begins
there is still talk of being able to
build new deals with workers but for the
time being talk is all it is Ed Conway
Sky News